you uh
self-terminating is a really interesting
idea that you talk about quite a bit
first of all what is a self-terminating
system and
i think you have a sense correct me if
i'm wrong that
human civilization as it currently is is
a self-terminating system
why do you have that intuition combined
with the definition of what
self-terminating means
okay so if we look at
human societies historically human
civilizations
uh it's not that hard to realize that
most of the major
civilizations and empires of the past
don't exist anymore so they had a life
cycle they died for some reason
so we don't still have in the early
egyptian empire or inca or maya or aztec
or
any of those right and so they
they terminated sometimes it seems like
they were terminated from the outside in
war sometimes it seems like they
self-terminate when we look at easter
island it was a self-termination
um so uh let's go ahead and take an
island situation if i have an island
and we're consuming the resources on
that island faster than the resources
can replicate themselves and there's a
finite space there
that system is going to self-terminate
it's not going to be able to keep doing
that thing
because you'll get to a place of there's
no resources left
and then you get uh so now
if i'm utilizing the resources faster
than they can replicate
or fasten they can replenish and i'm
actually growing our population the
process i'm even
increasing the rate of the utilization
of resources
i might get an exponential curve and
then hit a wall and then just collapse
the exponential curve rather than do an
s curve or some other kind of thing
um so self-terminating system is
any system that depends upon a substrate
system that is debasing its own
substrate
it is debasing what it depends upon so
you're right
that uh if you look at empires they rise
and fall throughout human history
but but not this time bro we're
this one's gonna last forever that's i
like that idea
i think that if we don't understand why
all the previous ones failed we can't
ensure that and so i think it's very
important to understand it well so that
we can
have that be a designed outcome with
somewhat
decent probability so where it's sort of
in terms of consuming the resources on
the island
we're a clever bunch and we keep coming
up
especially when on the horizon
there is a termination point we keep
coming up with clever ways of avoiding
disaster
of avoiding collapse of constructing
this is where technological innovation
this is where growth comes in
coming up with different ways to improve
productivity and the way society
functions such that we consume less
resources or get a lot more from the
resources we have
so there's some sense in which there's a
human ingenuity is a source for optimism
about the future of this particular
system that uh
that may not be self-terminating if if
there's more
innovation than there is consumption
so um overconsumption of resources just
one way i think can self-terminate we're
just
kind of starting here but um
there are reasons for optimism and
pessimism then they're both worth
understanding and there's failure modes
on understanding either without the
other
um as we mentioned previously there
there's what i would call naive techno
optimism naive techno capital optimism
that says stuff just has been getting
better and better and we wouldn't want
to live in the dark ages and tech has
done all this awesome stuff and
um we know the proponents of those
models
and this stuff is going to kind of keep
getting better of course there are
problems but human ingenuity rises to it
supply and demand will solve the
problems whatever
would you put red car as well on that or
in that bucket is there some specific
people you have in mind or naive
optimism is
truly naive to where you're essentially
just have an optimism that's blind to
any kind of realities of the way
technology progresses
i don't think that anyone
who thinks about it and writes about it
is perfectly naive
gotcha but there might it's a platonic
ideal there
there might be a bias in the nature of
the assessment
i would also say there's kind of naive
techno pessimism
and there are
um critics of technology
i mean you read the unabomber's
manifesto on why
technology can't not result in our
self-termination so we have to take it
out before it gets any further
but also if you read a lot of the x-risk
community you know bostrom and
friends it's like our total number of
existential risks
and the total probability of them is
going up
and so i think that there are
we have to hold together where our
positive possibilities and our risk
possibilities are both
increasing and then say for the positive
possibilities to be realized long term
all of the catastrophic risks have to
not happen
any of the catastrophic risks happening
is enough to keep
that positive outcome from occurring so
how do we ensure that none of them
happen
if we want to say let's have a
civilization that doesn't collapse
so again uh collapse theory it's worth
looking at books like um
the collapse of complex societies by
joseph tainter it does an
analysis of that
many of the societies fell for for
internal
institutional decay civilizational decay
reasons
um beaudrillard in simulation and
simulacra looks at a very different way
of looking at how institutional decay in
the collective intelligence
of a system happens and it becomes kind
of more internally parasitic on itself
um obviously jared diamond made a more
popular book called collapse
and as we were mentioning the
anti-catheria mechanism has been getting
attention in the news lately but it's
like
a 2 000 year old clock right like like
metal gears
and does that mean we lost like 1500
years of technological progress
um and from a society that was
relatively
technologically advanced um
so what i'm interested in here is being
able to say okay well
why did previous societies fail
can we understand that abstractly enough
that we can
make a civilizational model that isn't
just trying to solve
one type of failure but solve the
underlying things that generate the
failures as a whole
are there some underlying generator
functions or patterns
that would make a system
self-terminating and can we solve those
and have that be the kernel of a new
civilizational model that is not
self-terminating
and can we then be able to actually look
at the categories of x-rays we're aware
of and see that we actually have
resilience in the presence of those not
just resilience but anti-fragility
and i would say for the optimism to be
grounded
it has to actually be able to understand
the risk space well
and have adequate solutions for it so
can we try to
dig into some basic intuitions about the
underlying
sources of catastrophic failures of the
system
and over consumption that's built into
self-terminating systems
so both the over-consumption which is
like the slow death
and then there's the fast death of
nuclear war and all those kinds of
things
agi biotech bioengineering
nanotechnology now my favorite
nanobots okay
nanobots are my favorite because it
sounds so cool to me that i could just
know that i would be one of the
scientists that would be full steam
ahead
in building them without
sufficiently thinking about the negative
consequences i would definitely be
i would be podcasting all about the
negative consequences but
but when i go back home i'd be i just in
my heart know the amount of excitement
is a dumb descendant of vape no offense
to apes
uh so i want to backtrack on my previous
uh comments
about uh negative comments about apes
uh that i have that sense of excitement
that uh would result in problems so
sorry a lot of things said but
what can we start to pull it a thread
because you've also provided kind of a
beautiful
general approach to this which is this
dialectic synthesis or just
rigorous empathy whatever whatever word
we want to put to it
that seems to be from the individual
perspective is one way to sort of
live in the world as we try to figure
out how to construct
non-self-terminating systems so what
what are some underlying sources
yeah first i have to say um
i i actually really respect
drexler for emphasizing grey goo and
engines of creation back in the day
um to make sure the world was paying
adequate attention to the risks of the
the nanotech um as someone who was right
at the
cutting edge of what could be um
there's definitely game theoretic
advantage to those who focus on the
opportunities and
don't focus on the risks or pretend
there aren't risks um
because they get to market first
um and then they externalize all of the
costs through
limited liability or whatever it is to
the commons or wherever happen to have
it other people are going to have to
solve those but now they have the power
and capital associated the person who
looked at the risks and tried to do
better design and go slower
is probably not going to move into
positions of as much power influences
quickly so this one of the issues we
have to deal with is some of the
the bad game theoretic dispositions in
the system relative to its own
stability and the key aspect to that
sorry to interrupt is the externalities
generated
yes
you